Als ich vor drei jahren das ende des fernsehens in fünf jahren vorausgesagt, habe da habe
ich mich einerseits aber andererseits auch nicht tatsächlich spielt online eine immer größere rolle
und wie beim telefon droht irgendwann die abschaltung der alten technik die verbreitung über
Internet bietet allen sendern wie zu schauen so viele vorteile dass es nur noch eine frage der zeit ist wann satelliten
Terrestrisches tv und kabel-tv abgeschaltet werden aber wo habe ich mich dann. Gehört jetzt sind klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Anfang diesen jahres geschah etwas das den fernsehfans die augen geöffnet hat die handball weltmeisterschaft
wurde nämlich nicht, im fernsehen übertragen
Sondern im internet
Handball sponsor dkb die deutsche kreditbank sprang ein und übertrug die wm auf ihrer webseite
anders wäre eine übertragung nämlich nicht möglich gewesen und jetzt kommt es aus technischen und
lizenzrechtlichen gründen sprich eine übertragung
im fernsehen waren nicht möglich weil dort die lizenzbedingungen nicht eingehalten werden konnten jedenfalls
im free tv das ist nämlich über die grenze hinweg nicht nur in deutschland empfangbar und die lizenz gab es aber nur für
deutschland die ard oder das zdf hätten dafür ihr programm verschlüsseln müssen
Unmöglich nur im internet konnte gewährleistet
Werden dass die wm auch nur in deutschland empfangen werden kann über ip adressen ist ganz einfach
Zu ermitteln wo die zuschauer jeweils die spiele sehen und so kann der empfang exakt auf das territorium
begrenzt werden tv kann das nicht eine veraltete technologie
Und wer hätte gedacht dass hier die alte technologie an ihre grenze stößt
Im wahrsten sinne des wortes nur ip technologie
Also die protokollierte übertragung der daten ist dazu in der lage das fernsehen wohlgemerkt als technologie wird so
schneller ausgedient haben als wir bisher angenommen haben denn durch die immer aggressiver verteidigten lizenzen und
erlösmodelle werden solche gebietsschutz fragen immer wichtiger und noch etwas wird fernsehen das leben schwer machen genau die
Programme die davon betroffen sind live events und sportübertragung
profitieren von der ip-technologie nur ihr können total flexibel ohne jede einschränkung zusätzliche daten video streams usw
übertragen werden ein fantastischer mehrwert den fernsehen nicht bieten kann, zudem sind
im netz die technischen entwicklungen viel schneller hier gibt es bereits 4 k
360 grad und so weiter ob es das noch über herkömmliche tv technologie geben wird
höchst fraglich und inzwischen zeigte sich auch in den daten der fernsehnutzung der zenit ist überschritten
bis 2010 gingen die tägliche sehdauer
Im tv immer weiter nach. Oben bis zu 223 minuten täglich fast vier stunden, im schnitt seitdem
Passierte aber nichts mehr und es wächst nur noch die internetnutzung
Im letzten jahr so stark wie nie in der jungen zielgruppe von 14 bis 29 jahren ist die reichweite. Im internet inzwischen
Höher als im fernsehen es steht schon 51 zu 46 prozent?
Dh mit online-video werden 51 prozent der jungen zuschauer täglich erreicht mit dem fernsehen nur noch 46 prozent
Letzte woche war ich auf dem panel des web tv
monitor der blm der bayerischen landeszentrale für medien zu gast und auch hier zeigte sich es kommt etwas in bewegung immer
professionellere angebote erreichen netz immer mehr zuschauer hinzu kommen die geänderten werberichtlinien auf youtube träsch wird immer öfter
ausgeklammert und
hochwertige inhalte erzielen deutlich höhere einnahmen schon 2010 hatte ich das damals beim youtube video advisory board gefordert erst jetzt
2017 wurde es in die tat umgesetzt und das erst nachdem sich die werbeindustrie beschwert hatte zu erleiden
Jetzt hier auch tolle und renommierte angebote und youtube muss hier unbedingt noch nachjustieren aber generell ist die entwicklung
in die richtung qualität eine gute wenn sich nicht mehr rechnet wird er verschwinden und
Qualitativ gute programme haben bessere chancen es ist eine vielversprechende entwicklung
Im bereich online-video ach ja und wobei ich mich geirrt
habe
auf der anderen seite wird fernsehen noch lange leben und die sehdauer wird nur langsam nach unten gehen die generation fernsehen wird nämlich immer älter
Und sieht immer mehr fernsehen die 90 jährigen die zehn stunden am tag fernsehen werden noch
lange für eine ordentliche durchschnittliche sehdauer sorgen über die neuen chancen von
online-video spreche ich übrigens morgen auf der b 3 biennale in frankfurt auf dem panel neue
Plattformen neue formate neues geld für weitere infos hier klicken. Um 11.15. Geht es los
Ich freue mich auf jeden der kommt und hier geht es weiter mit dafür drauf klicken die schule der zukunft
ansonsten bis dahin
bleibt dran